now thank you so much for staying with
us here at 4 30. I'm Christian Cas I'm
Kirsten Joyce you know we talk a lot
about adults getting behind the wheel
intoxicated but police say teenagers are
also making these poor choices Ryan
Matthey joins us live with more on how
police are getting Santa Claus involved
Ryan
Kirsten just on Saturday a 19 year old
caused a fiery Collision here two
vehicles igniting on fire One driver
passing away and the other driver police
tell us the teen driver both admitted to
smoking marijuana and drinking tequila
before getting behind the wheel that
scene is what officials are hoping to
paint for high schoolers to get them to
drive safer he was coming back from a
party he was drunk he was behind the
wheel seventeen-year-old Alessandra
Gonzalez details a family friend she's
known since birth that almost lost his
life when he drove drunk he's learning
how to talk again he has to learn how to
walk again I know people that do it
sometimes sometimes on The Daily and 17
year old Marcos benavidez says it's more
common amongst teens than parents think
they tell me stuff like oh yeah like but
it was like really hard for me to drive
like I didn't like it that way
the distracted and unsafe driving
yielding deadly collisions like this one
in North Las Vegas that killed nine
people back in January Metro Police
reports of the nearly 18 thousand
vehicle collisions this year over 5 000
of them ended in a DUI arrest of those
who survived
this is what those crashes could look
like Windows shattered the roof torn off
thankfully this was just a demonstration
for high school students as part of
Sunrise hospitals Santa is coming to
town please don't hit him event it's
meant to deter these kids from ending up
in a vehicle like this a trauma is
actually the number one cause of death
in teenagers and sunrise trauma medical
director Dr Chris Fisher hoping the
hypothetical visual makes real life
impacts it infects us as Physicians as
our staff and have to tell parents you
know the gravity of their injuries or so
forth Just because they made one mistake
it's hard
now of course this comes just as the
holiday travel and season as a whole
kicks in but it's not just drinking and
smoking they're worried about looking
away from the road specifically on a
phone just like this they say that
slightest movement looking away from the
road could mean the difference between
your life and other people's life and
death reporting live near Lindell and
Flamingo Ryan Matthey 8 news now thank
you Ryan Sunrise Hospital also reports
caring for more than 5 000 trauma
patients just this year from distracted
and intoxicated driving collisions and
the most recent data from 2020 shows
some 2 800 teens were killed in crashes
like the one that Ryan mentioned Across
the Nation